[Music]
spinnaker for Google cloud platform is a
solution that lets you install spinnaker
the open source multi cloud application
delivery platform in Google cloud
platform with a couple of clicks to
start creating pipelines for continuous
delivery of your applications when you
open the management environment which
runs in cloud shell you can follow a set
of guided steps to install a
production-ready spinnaker instance in a
new google kubernetes engine cluster in
minutes using Google's recommended
settings you can change many of the
installation parameters if desired
including installing spinnaker in an
existing GK cluster spinnaker for Google
cloud platform also integrates your
spinnaker installation with other Google
cloud services such as cloud build
container registry and stack driver once
the installation process is complete you
can access the spinnaker UI via port
forwarding or automatically configure a
secured endpoint using cloud identity
aware proxy with the valid SSL
certificate
the management environment provides many
helpers to simplify ongoing
administration of your spinnaker
instances the configuration of each
instance is automatically and securely
backed up for auditing and fast recovery
helpers are provided to connect
spinnaker to new to K clusters and to
create accounts to deploy to Google
compute engine and Google App Engine and
other GCP projects you also have access
to the hal and spin command-line tools
giving you full control of your
spinnaker instances if needed the
solution lets you add sample pipelines
and applications to spinnaker that
demonstrate best practices for
deployments to kubernetes VMs and more
devops teams can use these as starting
points to provide golden path deployment
pipelines tailored to their company's
requirements the hello world web app
application for example demonstrates a
continuous delivery setup that builds
the application with cloud build and
deploys it first to staging and then to
production with spinnaker
once the staging deployment is completed
a manual judgment determines whether to
continue with the deployment to
production spinnaker for Google cloud
platform is pre integrated with Google
pops up for notifications and can also
be linked to slack email and other
notification channels
the deployment to production
demonstrates a number of good practices
such as automated roll back when the
validation tests fail and the hot
standby period after successful
validation in case something unexpected
happens
we can see the kubernetes resources
spinnaker is managing in the spinnaker
UI and can go straight to our deployed
app to check things out you can try out
the solution today just search for
spinnaker for Google cloud platform on
cloud or Google com